cher journal ça m'énerve quand les gens
disent que je suis timide
je suis pas timide je suis pudique
nuance les gens ne voient deux mois que
ce que je veux bien leur montrer le
rester privées c'est tout alors d'accord
je te les cris à toi cher journal mais
je sais très bien que personne ne lira à
part ma mère peut-être bon coucou maman
si tu me lis mais sinon je vois pas qui
serait intéressé à force de tout cacher
j'ai remarqué que j'ai développé une
sorte d'étrange capacités attention je
ne dis pas que je suis hors norme
même si j'ai quand même fait un test de
personnalité qui me qualifiais très
largement de surdoué
oui bon ça va on fait tout ça mais il
faut bien se rendre à l'évidence
j'ai le pouvoir d'être invisible alors
je ne fais pas souvent exprès c'est vrai
mais je dois quand même dire que c'est
un pouvoir à ces pratiques qui me permet
par exemple de m'extirper de toutes les
conversations complètement inintéressant
en tout quel jeu suit quotidiennement
confrontés et pour mettre fin au débat
c'est pain au chocolat c'est tout mais
au moins personne ne m'écoute je devrais
peut-être songer à partager ce pouvoir
avec les quelques personnes que
j'aimerais bien voir disparaître et
celle qui malgré tous mes efforts ne
voit pas à travers moi je me demande si
je ne devrais pas mettre à profit cette
transparence pour combattre le mal par
exemple le mal sans eux on est bien
d'accord tous les mâles ne sont pas le
mal il existe plein d'hommes bien en
appelant ses paypal voilà pourquoi je ne
dis rien tu comprends mieux maintenant
je me demande si les gens sont au
courant que je suis cette super héroïne
à laquelle il ne s'identifie pas
pourquoi vouloir à tout prix être
quelqu'un alors qu'on sait très bien que
personne n'est parfait
alors attention je ne dis pas que je
suis personne mais je ne suis pas grand
monde et c'est parfait
on est quoi 2,3 dans ma tête à tout
casser et franchement c'est largement
suffisant on n'a pas besoin d'être plus
[Musique]